the leader of the squad could be in some
big trouble a house ethics investigation
claims that AOC may have violated
federal law whether Infamous tax the
rich Met Gala appearance aoc's lawyers
apparently tried to warn her to be quote
extra careful about going to the
exclusive event where tickets can cost
thirty five thousand dollars a pop but
AOC one anyway after snagging two free
tickets and that's not all the report
also claims she racked up thousands of
dollars for her dress shoes hair makeup
and other goodies and then stiffed the
vendors by not paying them for months
AOC of course blames a staffer for not
settling the tab all right I'll start
with you Dana the truth is that she
begged even though there's an email
apparently that indicates her lawyer
said you have to be very careful about
this you can't take seventy thousand
dollars worth of tickets from a company
that has uh lobbyists like Vogue and yet
she was insistent and you know it's not
even in her District I mean why was she
why was it so important well one it was
important for her to get attention
that's a number one job number one and
also that she wanted to wear the dress
tax the rich and also look into the
dressmaker that's a little bit of an
interesting story too woman never pays
her taxes
um this is a real challenge for public
officials initially when they're like
wait what are we supposed to do yeah
Vogue knows Vogue knows what the rules
are and they went to her anyway she goes
to lawyer Lori says don't do it she says
I'm doing it anyway but the other thing
is do you know how many there is a
treasure Trove of quotes from her
talking about how when she was a
bartender she was lowly paid and that
there needs to be something that is done
for people who work jobs where they
don't get paid as much as other people
right so she Ben is trying to stiff the
makeup artist the hair stylist everybody
who is basically trying to chase down
500 500 to do her hair honestly but
anyway that's what the charge was if you
if this is a warning if you you're going
to do work for Alexandria ocasio-cortez
ask for the money up front yeah because
then what happened is then AOC then
throws her staffer who doesn't even work
for her anymore under the bus and says I
didn't know I don't believe that she's
in trouble with the
ethics office and this will be a stain
on her remember her claim to fame in her
first year as a congresswoman was
chasing thousands of high-paying jobs
out of her District by making sure that
Amazon didn't put a warehouse there well
you know it's not only that Jesse I mean
the the dress let me just expound a
little on on what Dana was saying a hot
Couture gown would cost about ten
thousand dollars apparently there was a
lot of negotiations and going back and
forth that they got it down to 1300 and
then I think it was 300 she ultimately
paid there was incredible negotiation
going on she kept fighting paying from
the get-go yeah tax the rich and stiff
the poor that's AOC and she's the it
girl so rich people do favors for her
for good press why is a bun 500 she's
wearing a bun I don't know if that's 500
bucks I have so much outrage and let's
just say I have 10 gallons of outrage am
I going to spill a gallon on this
well the lying mad scientist Anthony
fauci's on the hook for a pandemic that
he covered up or I don't know the
Chinese spies bribing the Biden family
with diamonds and millions in cash I
don't know AOC is unethical I don't know
if I can fake enough outrage I will try
hey
I'm actually I'm really upset by that
that's okay Jessica the one person who
got paid was the manicurist she insisted
on getting paid ahead of time with a
manicure
critically important
so I feel like this is one of those
stories and we do this a lot where
people in conservative media are paying
attention they're really upset about
this and people liberal media have a
completely different takeaway right so
the tax storage stress is Iconic now
right if you talk to gen Z's about it
that's one of the images that's
enshrined in their minds also her doing
that dance outside of her office
conservative Representatives went after
about it Etc but I do remember when we
were covering this originally
we were focused on the fact that she was
going to this event and everyone who was
serving was masked right it was right at
that kind of Crescendo moment where we
were saying people are vaccinated they
should be able to move on with their
lives and it became a class issue again
right that you have these people that
are paying hundreds of you know by the
end hundreds of thousands of dollars to
be there Etc and they're being served by
people who are not
worthy of the same air at this point
um but that fits into the same kind of
echo chamber about this and I think
that's how it will go down in history
the fact that you retained a lawyer
specifically to look into this I think
indicates that she intended to pay well
no she retained the lawyer and you told
her don't do it she did it anyway now
let's make an outfit okay all right Greg
you know what the point that Jessica
made is an important one and that is if
you'll recall when she came in they were
all the masked people behind her
carrying the whatever the veil or
whatever is behind her down everything
everything about her is a juxtaposition
between the things she says and the
things she really really wants by the
way an Ethics investigation into
politicians is like using a lice comb on
a hobo so you're going to find a lot of
stuff she came in that dress she had
people holding the train in masks it was
a perfect view for somebody wearing a
tax the rich rich dress and then you
have to think about the one thing that
nobody everybody just assumes that's a
great message tax the rich it's like
it's like wow how long did that take but
I just want to let you know the rich
paid most of the taxes so it's it's like
you want you should say it should have
been more let's tax the rich even more
until we no longer have any rich people
left and then we'll move on to the
middle class and then we'll go on even
further because that's exactly what
happens you run out of the rich or the
rich run away from your state it's been
over what a million people have left New
York am I right
yeah I'll just say it yeah a million
people because I believe it's more than
it's more than what's left California
but anyway so you can keep taxing them
and you and also I want to know does she
use Amazon like does she order like does
she get her air filters and her bath
towels like everybody else does from
Amazon the dog poop bags all that stuff
because I mean she's taking advantage of
the company that she didn't want in her
own backyard she she is as Elite as you
can get from the dress to the not in my
own backyard Persona to the electric car
to the French Bulldog oh that was she
got into politics not to change things
but to change her life she wanted a high
status which he got and she wanted to be
exempt from the very rules she wants to
enforce on others so she's she's
personally doing a great job and a 500
bun yes it's like a wedding style though
yeah you always you pull it back and put
a little bit I went on Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming anyway
on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now